in diesem film geht es um marian es er
wurde zu 16 jahren haft wegen mordes
verurteilt für mich war das einfach nur
ein schock ich uns wirklich nicht los
dieser vorwurf dass ich kannte hatte
umgebracht haben soll
mit brennspiritus übergossen ich kunst
kann das urteil mord durch brandstiftung
doch ein neues brandgutachten lässt
daran zweifeln diese tat hat so nicht
stattgefunden
mit sicherheit nicht
für marion es ist es der
hoffnungsschimmer der ihn aus dem
gefängnis bringen soll
doch erfolgreiche
wiederaufnahmeverfahren sind im
deutschen strafrecht äußerst selten wenn
ein roter einmal rechtskräftig geworden
ist dann ist es quasi die höhere weil
dieses urteil bekommen hat und das darf
nicht in frage gestellt werden
mariannes kämpft bis heute um seine
unschuld marian es ist wieder ein freier
mann nach seiner haftentlassung im
sommer ist er nach wien gezogen
hier will er ein neues leben beginnen
doch dieser eine tag vor 16 jahren lässt
ihn einfach nicht los
es ist der fünfzehnte juni 2004 im
hamburger kleingartenverein 160 steht
eine gartenlaube in flammen die lokalen
nachrichten berichten
die feuerwehr war mit 22 mann ausgerückt
konnte aber nichts mehr ausrichten
der mann der hier gerade getröstet wird
ist marian
also ich kann mich erinnern dass ich da
ging vier halb fünf
dass sich daran diese gartenlaube ankam
und bin ich zum nachbarn keine kunden
mehr informationen geben wo die tante
herne ist er nancy tante hanni die
rentnerin hannelore s hatte in der
gartenlaube übernachtet verkohlter
leichnam wird zwischen dem brand schon
geworden
ich bin in tränen ausgebrochen wenn
möglich auf die knie gefallen und bin in
tränen ausgebrochen
die polizei hält sein verhalten für
verdächtig marian ist in einem desolaten
zustand er hat sich am abend zuvor
heftig mit seiner freundin gestritten
dann die nacht durchgemacht und sich
betrunken
die polizei nimmt ihn mit aufs revier
zunächst wird er als zeuge verhört sagt
aus dass er zur laube gefahren sei um
seinen rausch auszuschlafen
sr häufiger bei tante hanni gewesen habe
ihr unter anderem bei handwerksarbeiten
geholfen zeugen von dem angriff
eigentlich sehr locker bis zu der frage
ob ich schon jemals mit der polizei zu
tun gehabt habe oder mit brandstiftung
und dann habe ich wahrheitsgemäß
beantwortet dass ich ein höchster berg
man muss gehabt habe ja und das hat mir
dann das genick gebrochen
tatsächlich wurde er als jugendlicher in
österreich zu einer mehrmonatigen
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt unter anderem
wegen brandstiftung
personen kamen damals nicht zu schaden
doch die ermittler werden hellhörig denn
als gutachter die abgebrannte laube in
hamburg untersuchen finden sie an den
kleidungsreste der toten spuren eines
chemischen stoffes zwei butter nun der
findet sich auch in brennspiritus marian
es werden haarproben entnommen an den
händen zeigen sie merkmale hoher
hitzeeinwirkung das einzige indiz für
diese thermische einwirkung auf meine
haut auf meine kirchen auf den fingern
und das habe ich auch erklärt dass wir
am vortag gequält haben das überzeugt
die ermittler nicht
ein zeuge sagt zudem aus dass marian es
der nacht kein geld mehr bei sich gehabt
habe doch die polizei stellt 80 euro in
marians portemonnaie sicher damit
scheint auch das motiv klar
hunderte strömen um diese straf- dazu
vertreten hätte ich den menschen
marian es passt perfekt ins raster
vorbestraft ohne alibi und unmittelbar
nach der tat am tatort
die haben schon denken und gesucht und
mich dabei gefunden und ich schon der
polizist damals gesagt hat zur falschen
zeit am falschen ort gewesen
nach sechs verhandlungstagen fällt das
urteil lebenslang wegen mordes
seine schwester kann es nicht fassen das
war für mich wie gesagt zuerst bin ich
mal umgekippt wirklich ohnmächtig
geworden weil ich kann es nicht glauben
aber trotzdem was ein funken hoffnung
okay das ist ja jetzt noch nicht alles
man kann ja in revision gehen man kann
ja ja man wird schon irgendwas machen
doch die revision wird verworfen das
urteil rechtskräftig eine lebenslange
haftstrafe steht marian es bevor
jetzt gibt es für ihn nur noch eine
hoffnung eine wiederaufnahme des
verfahrens
die schwester kontaktiert gerhard strate
er gilt als spezialist für
wiederaufnahmeverfahren der
strafverteidiger war in einigen
aufsehenerregenden fällen mit seinen
anträgen erfolgreich
und das obwohl es in deutschland sehr
selten vorkommt dass über ein
rechtskräftiges urteil erneut verhandelt
wird
sein schlüssel zum erfolg es ist schon
wichtig dass man bei diesem verfahren
die akte zeile um zeile gelesen hat und
wirklich dann auch mit einem gewissen
spürsinn den schwachstellen des urteils
nachgibt eine schwachstelle die mine
strate zu erkennen
der von einem fall in berlin erfährt der
parallelen aufweist
es ist der fall von monika demokratie
verurteilt weil sie ihren vater mit
hilfe von brennspiritus ermordet haben
soll
grundlage für das urteil unter anderem
spuren von zwei butter nun wieder ein
hinweis auf brennspiritus doch das
urteil wird aufgehoben
2008 wird dem orga song schließlich
freigesprochen
der vater hatte wohl im bett geraucht
und war dabei eingeschlafen
zu diesem ergebnis waren gutachter
gekommen
das bett war aus holz und wenn holz
verbrennt wird ebenfalls zwei bieter nun
freigesetzt
eine erkenntnis die neue maßstäbe bei
brandgutachten setzte und eine mögliche
erklärung für den 2 butanol fund in der
hamburger gartenlaube
denn diese bestand zum teil aus
kiefernholz
ich habe mich zunächst sahen das
bundeskriminalamt gewarnt weil die in
berlin auch als sachverständiger tätig
waren
von den beamten erhält er den tipp den
brandexperten professor roland goertz zu
kontaktieren
drei monate lang untersucht er mit
seinem team den fall 2018 präsentiert
kürzt dann sein brandgutachten und
bestätigt die spuren von zwei booten
könnten tatsächlich durch das abbrennen
der laube entstanden sein
wie aber kam es zum brand meiner
einschätzung nach ist die ja relativ
stark alkoholisierte da mal auf der
couch mit einer zigarette eingeschlafen
in der gartenlaube kommt es zum
schwelbrand die rentnerin schläft auf
der couch und bemerkt nichts denn der
ganz entscheidende knackpunkt den wir
erst über eine computersimulation
verstanden haben ist dass die dame wohl
in dieser nacht wie so oft vorher
scheinbar auch die tür der gartenlaube
hat offen stehen müssen
die folge kalte luft strömt von außen
ein
dadurch bleibt es zwar auf höhe der
couch kühl doch darüber so das szenario
wird es immer heißer mit temperaturen
von über 600 grad
es kommt zum flash auf diese gartenlaube
war so aufgeheizt dass plötzlich alle
oberflächen schlagartig in brand geraten
in diesem augenblick für die betroffene
wachgeworden sollen die rentnerin
versucht sich aus den flammen zu retten
draußen bricht sie zusammen
sie stirbt im leichnam der verstorbenen
finden sich rußpartikel also zunge war
stark verrußt brennspiritus verbrennt
aber wieder weiß ohne ruß gehört ist
sich sicher
maria neshat die rentnerin nicht mit
brennspiritus übergossen und angezündet
es ist das erste und einzige mal dass
hinter einem gutachten geschrieben habe
dass dieses ereignis mit sicherheit
nicht stattgefunden hat hier ist es so
dass die widersprüche und die objektiven
anhaltspunkte die auf dokumentiert sind
so sehr gegen die tat prothese des
gerichts sprechen dass ich hier absolut
sicher bin dass dieser vom gericht
vermutete ablauf niemals stattgefunden
hat er schickt sein gutachten anwalt
strate gab es noch genau vor augen
dieses gutachten war so eindeutig dass
ich mir dachte das ist eigentlich
ein selbst genau zu diesem zeitpunkt
sitzt marian es bereits seit 14 jahren
im gefängnis
ich habe mir so ein maßband gebastelt
und habe jedes jahr keine tage keine
monate sondern jedes jahr ein zentimeter
abgeschnitten gehabt
[Musik]
dann erfährt er von den neuen
brandgutachten durch das gutachten
gelesen habe habe ich gedacht endlich
mal entlassung schon ist das doch er
bleibt im gefängnis eine wiederaufnahme
des verfahrens wird in mehreren
instanzen verworfen
es gibt ganz selten fälle wo das gericht
dass ich in einem
wiederaufnahmeverfahren mit dem alten
urteil befasst völlig unbefangen noch
einmal an die prüfung der tatsachen
herangeht bhatti erlebe ist immer nur
abwehr verteidigung des alten urteils
und das geschieht dann manchmal wirklich
mit zehn um mit clown im fall maria ness
argumentieren die gerichte das gutachten
von professor gerd sei unplausibel nicht
in der lage das urteil zu erschüttern
ich bin schon von der justiz da nicht
nur enttäuscht sondern auch entsetzt
hier haben richterinnen und richter auf
einmal sich zu brandexperten ja gemacht
und haben detailliert irgendwelche
naturwissenschaftlich technischen
aspekte eines gutachtens und auch dieses
falls diskutiert und erwogen
ohne nochmal einen experten zu befragen
und das finde ich also unter den
umständen das hier eben richterinnen und
richter ja über eine ganze biografie
eines menschen entscheiden und über sein
schicksal finde ich erschreckend
sie haben alles versucht aber marian es
musste seine strafe absetzen 16 jahre
ein monat 26 tage keine wiederaufnahme
keine rehabilitation in zweifel schuldig
sollten mögliche vier urteile in
deutschland einfacher angefochten werden
können schreibt es uns in die kommentare